hey there and welcome to this pro flows
quick tip i am cameron
and today i'm gonna toot my own horn
here for the analog glitch pack
i've got available over on
motionscience.tv if you haven't checked
out the analog glitch pack it's a pack
that uh myself and another guy ryan
feiguard put together
to give you elements that you can use
in your motion design or edits they're
really awesome
elements and i want to show you how you
can use
them in a really simple way so what i've
got here is the pack is brought in in
part two there's part one and part two
by running part two for this example
and i'm just gonna bring in a few of
them to show you how powerful they are
okay so
we're gonna bring one of them in here
and we're just going to
drag it in here and we're just going to
preview this um these are 4k
elements and this is a 1920 by 1080 comp
so you can see just by bringing in here
immediately
right how cool it is right so we can
kind of see glitch here
so look let's make the the type glitch
as well so i'm going to change this back
to normal
go to effect my favorite way to do this
is displacement mapping
select the analog glitch 36
and then just bump the values way up
here
so there you go we've got some
interesting
graphic glitching going on can change
this back to soft light if i wanted to
and a little challenging to see so what
i'll do is i'll just
actually bring the position over just a
hair
since we've glitched it to the right
there we go and almost duplicate
the layer that's looking pretty dope
it's even more dope if i undo this
let me show you a few other ways you can
do some cool stuff here so i'll change
this back to normal
i will turn off the glitch layer here so
you can see just that by itself
looks pretty legit change it from
i'm just going to replace 36 with 37.
you can see it gives it a little bit
different look there let's try 38 let's
bring 38 in let's see what that looks
like even more
serious type glitches that's pretty cool
as well something i could do with this
is i could go in i could maybe set like
a keyframe
now let's set a keyframe here
[Music]
maybe bring down the amount just a hair
you know something like that go to the
beginning here and just crank it
way up something like that so maybe it
transitions on
and let's see how that looks so maybe i
set a keyframe i would uh
make maybe make this do ease in and then
turn on my speed graph here
and really
you know that's pretty cool as well like
i said again you could turn this back on
if you wanted to you could make this
like a soft light
an overlay there's all different ways
you could do this
really increase the transparency maybe
bring down the transparency of this one
you get the idea so that is how you can
use the analog glitch elements i've had
a lot of people ask me like how would
you use these things i really am
interested in them
but i just don't know how i'd use them
this is just one very simple
example of how you could use these
elements if you like this
quick tip i would invite you to check
out pro flows plus over at
motionscience.tv
we've got lots of techniques trends
workflows
techniques that are way more involved
than just this there's a full-on lessons
series of lessons that teach you things
like glitching so i invite you to check
it out
that's all i got for you today